freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher
kommen ich bin heute britischen the
world und kommt gerne
wir haben einen traum
es geht so groß sind wie ich das gemacht
haben ihr kommen zur vorbereitung des
cinemaxx ein absolutes ehren frühstück
ich freue mich sehr darauf starten uns
zuallererst eine große schüssel und eine
waage und den 580 gramm je schlusslicht
soll heute speicherkarte war volle ich
habe auch einmal zehn um zucker dazu
gegeben eine prise salz ungefähr sechs
kam und jetzt zuletzt das eine weiche
butter
als nächstes wird zu ungefähr 250
milliliter milch und machen die laut ba
[Musik]
so wären eine gute temperatur erreicht
hier reden wir jetzt ein päckchen hefe
ein davon nicht zu heiß sein damit die
hilfe nicht stört es mich leute ich bete
dass das jetzt einfach funktioniert weil
beim letzten mal ganz ganz schlimm so
leute ich hab das jetzt so gut es ging
aufgelöst ich hoffe einfach dass es
funktioniert bei der ladung weiß ich
auch nicht genau das fügen wir jetzt
hier hinzu und außerdem die zwei ganze
eier und da stehen ja noch unsere
rührschüssel andere das einmal durch
[Musik]
wenn das ganze neues verknetet ist
kommen jetzt auch schon raus
oder nehmen wir wissen die arbeitsfläche
und dann können wir auch schon im teig
rausholen ihr seht schon das gut klebrig
jetzt schlüssel habe ich sauber gemacht
nehmen wir uns ein wenig höher und damit
die schlüssel und wir machten eineinhalb
stunden hier sollte sich dann in der
größe verdoppeln wenn das nicht klappt
dann hat freunde in den letzten stunden
waren eine emotionale achterbahn ich
glaube aber detail ist aufgegangen
und ich habe ja alles weiter vorbereitet
ich habe hier 250 gramm braunem zucker
und 17 gemeinden sind und hier zum
nachfragen butter auf petrochemischer
hamm az und braunen zucker den streuen
wir gleich auf unsere mit eigenen ideen
weiter verarbeiten dann würde ich sagen
kann sehr erleichtert er ist auch
gegangen
das geschafft dann wollen wir mal
unseren teil heraus wird auf jeden fall
der handelstage zur dänischen vize
ausfallen
sehr schön portiert schnappen wir uns
unsere geschmolzene butter um sie dann
gleich zu verstreichen
also ich habe echt mühe gegeben und ich
glaube das ist ganz gut verteilt ist und
jetzt kommen wir zum spaßigen partie
nehmen uns einfach unsere mischung von
verteilen das kann sich gleichmäßig ihr
seht leute unmengen von dem zucker sind
drauf und jetzt wollen wir das ganze
einfach schön eng zusammen
das tolle wetter ansagen
es ist viel größer geworden wollen weil
ich halt noch ein bisschen gescratcht
habe nach außen jetzt schneiden wir
unsere sales in fünfeinhalb zentimeter
groß hier haben wir 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 perfekte zähne raus und so
platzieren wir jetzt immer drei von
unseren zähnen rolls nebeneinander
ihr versteht wie es sein soll wir machen
das ganze morgen früh deshalb geben wir
sie über nacht im kühlschrank freunde
ist es ja nicht ich hab ich damals noch
für eine stunde rausgeholt ihr seht
schon sie sind gut aufgeteilt in fünf
der 15 bis 20 minuten oder teilten
unsere single basis und wünschte ihr
könnt ihr das riechen brauchen aber noch
ein bisschen die kölner trafen schon mal
um unser eissing brauchen dafür 120
gramm frischkäse 90 gramm puderzucker
des films schott milch und dann in
elektrische den frischkäse zunächst
erstmal krimi wird es zu krass ist nicht
so lecker jetzt gehen wir auch unseren
puderzucker hinzu
nach jetzt haben wir unser perfektes
essen so alles fertig wir lassen es
jetzt ganz kurz abkühlen und dann machen
wir uns auch schon zu spät
[Musik]
das richtig die jungs trainings
gewünschte mehrheit halten
jetzt komm ich habe diesen hier wohl
beispiellos ist der greifen die dürfen
ja wieder einstellt wird die für die
lauberhorn
er weist der verein team trophy mehlis
adidas nike reebok grace victory gestern
abend angefangen also jemand von euch
schon mal gemacht als ersten mal fix
was sagt ihr habt euch durch mal kräftig
die gäste die hier sind ja vier punkte
waren das ist total schön matschig
gewesen wir haben die sozialisten total
geil ist es weniger trainierte moschee
hat er sehr sehr sehr lecker freut mich
sehr dass euch geschmeckt hat zehn von
zehn ist der perfekte start in den tag
die zeche auch deshalb gegen den
chinesen so freuen wir kommen zum mittag
ist und wir machen königsberger klopse
mit rote beete und kartoffeln also lasst
uns loslegen ist ein bisschen
aufwendiger das ganze ja das schöne
mittelgroße speisekartoffeln marschieren
habe ich auch noch nie gekocht muss ich
sagen die königsberger klopse sind und
ich muss auch die zimtschnecken heute
wurden vor leute ist es eigentlich im
wirklichen knocked out habe ja auch drei
stück gegessen dreieinhalb oder so das
ist so schlau war erwünscht gerade
kommen klar denken so todt wir nicht vom
essen aber es hat trotzdem geist hat
sich gelohnt aber ich mag es auch gerne
weil ich so traditionelle sachen so koch
heute abend so wie kann ich jetzt schon
mal verraten wird es auch wieder
traditionell und schön einfach wir
müssen wir für die königsberger klopse
mit einem eingeweichten brötchen
arbeiten das heißt ich weiß du erstmal
einfach schüssel brötchen rein und
wasser dazu nun auf jeden fall schon
wieder knapp in der zeit so dann machen
wir auch weiter wirklich mit den
königsberger klopsen wenn der mangel
eines brötchens nämlich immer so ein
papier teller und jetzt schneiden wir
uns eine große zwiebel schneiden der
länge nach 1 und würfeln
einfach schön dann schreiben wir uns
eine schüssel geben wir 400 gramm hat
dann eben unsere zwiebel einen esslöffel
senf so dann starten wir uns unser
brötchen dass wir eingereicht haben ist
jetzt schon total weich und wir
quetschen das eine aus also überhaupt
kein wasser mehr drin sein
dann können wir das ganze auch schon gut
durchkneten so sollte alles
zusammenhalten dann können wir jetzt
auch schöne kleine bällchen daraus
formen so denkt ist eine ganz gute größe
hier sind also unsere klöpse sondern
stelle ich auch schon kartoffeln und
wasser für die königsberger klopse auch
seien großzügig die kartoffeln kommen
wir einmal auf dann fahren wir die hitze
runter und lassen die schönen gar ziehen
so hier vorne kochten das heißt wir
gehen bei den kartoffeln mal runter von
der hitze der dumme herd nicht schwer
ein kissen in die feinen noch lange
nicht runter also alles super
das wasser kocht jetzt auch für die
klopse und aus dem wasser machen wir
brühe und zwar rinderbrühe ordentlich
gehäufter esslöffel früher rein und dann
trocken wir es schon direkt in das
siedende wasser unsere klopse hinein und
kochen sie so für ca 10 15 minuten und
chili an weiteren top indem wir unsere
soße machen so da geben wir zu gute 50
gramm butter hinein und machen wie
gesagt eine mehlschwitze das heißt
nichts anderes als butter rein
heißmachen gleiche anteil mehreren
durchführen und dann auf gießen mit
brühe in unserem fall also 50 gramm
butter kreis machen und daran kommt
jetzt das mehl da weiß man wie gesagt
wichtig einfach die ganze zeit schön zu
rühren und jetzt können wir uns hier
direkt eine gute gute ecke von unserer
sauce von den königsberger klopsen
nehmen also 500 milliliter auf jeden
fall richtig gas geben aufkochen aber
wie gesagt ein bisschen kochen lassen
damit der mail geschmack ausgeht damit
die soße noch ein bisschen voller wird
ein guter schuss sahne natürlich hier
salz pfeffer auch nicht vergessen
denke dass es uns gut gelungen stellst
zur seite so die kartoffeln sind fertig
warum weil die von der messerspitze
runter fallen dann bleibt uns nur noch
der letzte mitspieler rote beete dann
machen wir aber gar nicht viel außer die
einfach entscheidung zu steil so einfach
sagt das ist so ein bisschen hübsch
aussieht vielleicht auf dem teller und
lasst euch schmecken ja nein danke und
ich also rote beete wendigen bestellen
kann nicht nur den preis um rhede
weitergeben er hat sehr gut regel sehr
gut gemacht richtigkeit wichtigkeit sagt
russell noch einmal die ziele drin
es ist nämlich treffe es ist mir schon
dass ich nach der kirche so gut gemacht
jungs ich hoffe das war am mittag teuren
geschmack total mega lecker also sagen
dass die kartoffeln und gekochte
kartoffel ich liebe ist in die kassen so
so wachse ich sind wie deine passion
salzig
auch das bild ich habe nur einen
minuspunkt der rote beete die aus dem
glas schritt mir ein bisschen besser als
die frische wahrscheinlich nicht
konsumieren weil ja schon glas und
zucker eingelegt
das kann nicht sein aber ansonsten die
klopse die waren das noch ganz zartes
fleisch und die wie ich mag noch so
große ziele dazwischen
wirklich ich kann nur ein punkt abziehen
das neun punkte ich höre jetzt zehn
punkte gehen weil ich mal auch den
natürlichen geschmack und ich frage mich
durch einigen doch mit einigen noch
darauf dann machen wir nochmal einfach
kommen und damit wäre die bisschen
traurig
die trauer im kraft für das haben wir
essen und wir sehen uns nicht ich muss
das noch gleich ein geiles brot kaufen
aber das muss schnell die bewertung
stelle aufgerissen kirche leer getrunken
ich hoffe ihr seid großartig großartig
bin ja komplett in der hand während
machen einen punkt dahinter
also durch ich habe das heute morgen
danach sind schnecken gemerkt ich was
und wann es zu stecken natürlich der
fans haben das hatte ich noch nie das
hat noch nie so freunde zu mir lampe es
ist so weit wir kommen zum abendessen
wird
ich habe einen schönen sport gehören
mittlerweile erkennen dass auch jeder
das ist mein lieblings becker habe wo
ich eigentlich nur philipp persönlicher
kurz einkaufen gehen rechnet selbst
finden
mit wandlungs treiben kann war schon
krass und damit machen wir nicht dass
ich das besonders gut kann
mit der one tolle sache denn ich bin
mark perry krieger drei stück
gleichzeitig rein erklärt ich glaube
dass entscheidest einen guten start ist
das deshalb darf jeden fall sparen und
irgendwie was billig ist so für 50 cent
die packung nehmen
denn dann können wir einen stichtag 1
ansonsten brauchen firmen sprachen macht
sich nicht viel aus dem automaten
schäden beispiel ein und macht manche
leute essen käse drauf weiß ich genau
wie die jungs ist da halten deshalb
mache ich erstmal nicht
das ist schon eine gute ecke butter aber
ich meine man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts
beide seiten einmal warten und dann
schön kross an thorsten zwischen 15
minuten bevor die jungs gleich wieder
kommen also das geht so vorstellen wenn
man das so schön mit mutter antwortet
dann hält es auch so ein bisschen krank
und die können berge rechtlichen
zubereitungen wissen an der seite liegen
lassen so danach packen wir dann auch
schon unseren schink wichtig ist das
niveau ist es ist kein strammer max eine
stramme lotte ich heute gelernt
ich würde diesen ruf von schwarzem humor
ins boot eingerüstet ist mache ich noch
eine kleine scheibe nicht aber ihr merkt
schon dass es sehr viele tomaten durch
den rauch schneidewind strom raus hier
ist krieg so etwa eine große unterschied
gemacht
wenn ich mit meinen händen irgendwie in
den kopf greifen aber diesmal muss ich
es gibt nämlich keine
so werden sagt nein wir hier kurz die
tomaten
jetzt haben wir ein bisschen öl in die
pfanne gegeben und jetzt schlagen wir
unsere spiegeleier hinein gehört auch
schon losgehen mit dem aufbau benötigen
natürlich eine scheibe brot dann kommen
da auch unsere schinken gehen wir mal
ganz vorsichtig mit ein bisschen salz
pfeffer zucker da kommen nur noch das 1
über petersilie zwei jungs haben wir
essen ja strammer max dazu mal erlebt
heute den traum eines jeden kindes das
noch nie getan kann die meisten
konsumenten ist auch klar aber könnt ihr
krankes kind ostmarken etwa haben die
ich habe auch ein paar leute bei meiner
research zum kramermarkt kommen auch aus
machen ja im automaten
roth sagen so einen braucht und dann
irgendwie dass eine frau direkt last wir
sind wie man sich so aufstellen wie war
es ausstoßen
sehr lecker aber die kombination mit
tomate axel mit symmetrischer gemacht
das päckchen salz ich liebe es also ich
bin wahrscheinlich komplett ist ja
erfurt ohne salz - und ziemlich genau
das richtige für dich
speck war aus dem schönen raum und ich
finde ich spannend gute portion häufig
auch mehr das nicht sein de witte
mehrere erstmals ohren gekommen sind
sehr sehr lecker und ich kann nicht
sagen ich dann das nach hause was noch
nicht ist noch leckerer ziemlich
vorgestellte ja freunde
das war wirklich eine folge persönlicher
pharma beim geschmack gute bewertung
zürich zu kochen und angenehme gäste ja
ihre teller den nächsten sonntag um 14
uhr spätestens wieder gucken unbedingt
auch bei den jungs und weise natürlich
verlinken